hey everybody and welcome to the pomp
podcast
I'm not your host Jason Calacanis I'm
the host of this week in startups but my
friend Anthony pump Leon oh you know
miss pump and I decided we would try to
do a crossover episode where the king of
crypto and the Prince of startups would
get together and answer your question so
it's a crossover episode between the
pomp podcast now if you're listening to
my podcast this week in startups would
you stop what you're doing in your
podcast player and do a search for pump
P OMP and find the pom-pom cast and
subscribe to it it's awesome and he
talks about crypto and he's very
objective and he's been on my pot and
he's awesome and it's great to catch up
with you pomp how are you doing I'm
doing great
this is also the pop podcast recording
which means that you have to go
subscribe to this week in startups I'm
laughing because right before we started
Jason said that this is a collab episode
similar to Nicki Minaj and Takashi 6:9
and we're still trying to figure out who
is who in the episode of collaboration
but yeah I mean I think it means one of
us has to take our top off and put
pasties on at some did you see the new
video oh I saw what is going on in the
world like it's just like people are
just naked to get YouTube views and I
certainly Nicki Minaj tweeted like this
is the fastest to like whatever a
hundred million views I'm like you're
topless of course it is my favorite
thing is Takashi six nine keeps going on
Instagram and making these videos that
says everyone said I was a rat because
he you know basically we ratted on his
prosecutors yep Phe then and he still is
under house arrest actually and he's
like and I'm still doing better numbers
than everyone else in the rap game so
you guys are just mad and it's kind of
like look man he's living under house
arrest doing these collabs and going
viral on the internet it's pretty wild
so basically they sent two video crew to
his house painted the corner of it red
or something and made like a little tiny
box for them to jump around in I mean
that kid's gonna get whacked
based on my experience from where I grew
up
if you talk that much and you poke that
many people it's just a matter of time
and it's not gonna happen in the next
two years it's gonna be like eight years
from now kids gonna get whacked cars
gonna flip on a highway nobody's got
maybe the brakes were not so good but
he's got to be careful man he uh before
he released this latest video he
actually went on Instagram and did an
hour-long
live stream beforehand and literally had
a list of rappers everyone from Snoop
Dogg all the way down and just went one
by one and just basically talked [ __ ] to
him I was like man he's telling me okay
I tried to sit through that song and I
was like my god this I could rap better
than this and I mean I sound terrible I
have a terrible voice he's horrible why
do people like him I don't get have you
dropped if you dropped a rap song it
would go viral for sure from 100 would
somebody take this episode and just
sample something we say that's clever
and make a pump and J cow crossover
video whatever but anyway you know it's
interesting you and I have debated
crypto a whole bunch we actually overlap
a lot more than people probably think
because people think I hate crypto but I
don't I just hated the ico scam and you
and I came to basic agreement on that so
my first question for you is about the
ICO scams and that whole chapter of
crypto is that actually over now and did
anything come out of that because I had
the founders of tezo's on I see they
settled a lawsuit and I'm wondering if
any of the projects that we heard about
what is it five years ago four years ago
three years ago and people going crazy
about this did any of those projects
ever result in an actual real company
that provides products or services
that's notable so let me separate two
things here one is there is very few if
any ICO still happening in the form that
they were happening specifically in the
United States and even internationally I
think that kind of came and went we'll
see if it comes back but right now
that's definitely been kind
tamper down by a lot of the regulatory
pressure in terms of what has been
produced the one thing that I definitely
will give credit to is if you take a
theorem right so it's not a company that
has a product or service it's a protocol
that definitely has become the second
most dominant network in the space so
they they get credit for that they did
an IC o---- went well they've been
proven to not be a security and we're
off to the races there in terms of most
of the other things people will disagree
with me on this but I tend to think that
you're right in that there just isn't
what you and I would expect kind of
measurable success there's some things
that are you know maybe interesting some
people who have built a product and kind
of are just now getting out in the space
but if you're a business that raised 10
20 50 100 million dollars in an IC o----
you know in the traditional technology
world you would expect a product you
would expect hundreds of employees like
you would expect some of these
milestones to be hid and we're just not
seeing that yet and I think that really
was kind of the concern all along why
are you giving people 250 million
dollars and they have an idea in a pitch
deck like I don't know it is that was
another concern I had and people are
like oh you're hating and I was like
well honestly I'm not hating because the
second this becomes legitimate and legal
you can be certain I will be on top of
it and I have a big platform so if I
SEOs turn out to be the thing the
syndicate comm will be an IC o---- token
and we will go all in on it and and we
just took a very cautious like wait and
see because I have something to lose
like I've got a pretty great life I
don't want to go to jail but looking
down this list of icos
telegram raised a billion seven I'm just
reading from a CNBC story dragon coin
raised 320 and I don't know if these
numbers are even legitimate anymore
something called who buy 300 million H
DAC 258 file coin I remember because my
friend of all was involved in that 257
million and that one seemed like an
interesting one to me because I believe
it was going to be cloud storage you
give your hard drive up and it's gonna
be some sort of cloud storage I had some
mixed feelings on that one but that one
seemed real I had Tesla's on the podcast
they race to 32 and they just gave some
money back they got sued
syren labs 157 Bank or 152 of that list
I just made obviously telegrams are real
products so putting that aside or any of
those legit now or do any of them like
you hear about any of them do you get
excited about any of them yes so I think
that Hobie is a real exchange it
operates it's relatively large I don't
know how much of that is because of the
IC o---- versus it was already gonna be
a successful thing and they had the IC
o---- the other ones for the most part
are either still kind of we're going to
do mode right so we're gonna launch this
we're gonna do all of this the one you
didn't mention is there was an EOS that
raised oh right Lily in dollars
Brock pears billion dollars yeah yeah
hey 20 I think a twenty five million
dollar SEC find on four billion raised
it's like the most profitable business
in the world I think that your credit
card fees would be larger I think it
feels like a credit card fee right
through and a half percent on a billion
pretty good yeah here's what I here's
what I will say yeah right is so you and
I are definitely on the same page of
like I was yelling screaming this is all
chaos and nonsense and like I can't
believe this is all happening and I
actually thought that the regulators
would be much more strict so the thing
that I probably was wrong on was they
seem to have not been as stringent as I
thought they would be but this also
happens in tech sometimes too so if you
look at you know there's magically
there's kwibi that there's a bunch of
these companies especially when Softbank
came to the market that they raised
hundreds of millions or even billions of
dollars free product and so I always go
back to like is that a sign of
late-stage economy stuff or is that a
sign of like crypto stuff right and I
don't yet have an answer yeah I mean let
me I'll take that as a question because
unpacking it if we just take kwibi as an
example there you have one of the most
successful media executives in the
history of media top five certainly in
Katzenberg pretty easy about to make
even pre product and as much as they've
been derided I do think they have three
million paid subs or something which is
from a cold start in
new brand not insignificant right
certainly they've gone further than
Netflix did in their first 10 years I
bet in terms of the number of
subscribers so that was interesting
magic leap actually has real technology
and that is a groundbreaking space a our
augmented reality but it does seem crazy
that people poured a ton of money in but
those were very sophisticated investors
obviously addressing Horowitz and other
people so as much of a mess as that is
people I have not seen the technology
but people have and there's something
real there so they definitely part of it
as late stage capitalism but I would
think these are two very different
buckets of capital right like an IC
o---- investor with somebody who
probably made a fortune on Bitcoin or
aetherium and was just rolling it over
that's definitely solvent and some of it
was actually people who missed kind of
the early successful ones and then said
oh what's the next one right because
remember Bitcoin didn't have an ICO
right so Bitcoin was kind of what you
would consider a traditional product it
was released to the world and kind of
went that way a theorem had the ICO but
there's a lot of investors I mean I
literally remember in 2017 there was a
number of times where people would be
like hey this company is raising twenty
million dollars and all you do is you
send crypto to a wallet and then just
like fill in this excel file with your
name and the amount you sent Wow and it
was like this it this isn't gonna end
well
hard money coming in like that I mean
with that with the KYC know your
customer and all the money laundering
issues you know that's just a recipe for
disaster but yeah I mean that we do see
some weird things where a company
pre-product and so I think on average
the icos were like the outliers in our
industry so I would I would freely admit
that the outliers in our industry did
look similar to some of those icos
but the interesting thing is kwibi did
get a product to market magically did
get their product to developers I
believe developers have the kits now so
it's you know the hit rate is going to
be very different I think why didn't
they launch products do you think was it
just that the people who built these
companies
and who were willing to take the risk of
being doing an ICO which was unclear
we're probably just not super qualified
to build products I don't know for sure
right each case is kind of keeps my case
but what I will say is I think you get
there was definitely some people who
raised money through icos that couldn't
have raised it in a more traditional
kind of venture capital type model so
there's a signaling right it was
signaling people or selecting P it was a
selection issue people who couldn't
clear mark an adventure cleared market
with anonymous global wallets
maybe that signals not as good of an
executor yes that was and I don't know
what percentage of them but that was
definitely 1% and another part of it was
people who believed in kind of the
decentralization so this whole idea of I
don't want the venture capitalists you
know to own a piece of my business I
want the people to own it I can kind of
bootstrap and network all that and the
third one is I actually think that there
was a lot of people who literally just
said well if someone's gonna give me two
hundred million dollars I'm gonna raise
two hundred million dollars right so
this position was hey let's do that
awesome
okay let me ask you let them ask you
this question okay where's them what's
the most money a company has raised in a
seed round that you invested in three
product okay great question
seed round pre-product hmm I am very
much of the belief in investing in
companies right but after they launch
their product and I can play with it so
I think a company like superhuman
because Raul had done a company before
was able to raise a decent chunk of
change in their seed round it was you
know many millions of dollars but it
wasn't over ten and then looking at
let's see I I was in a later round of
medium but I think I've probably raised
a decent chunk of change
so cereal founders like a Mark Pincus or
Elon with the boring company forget
about me being involved in them I'm not
in the boring company but
medium but elite around they tend to
raise 10 million for 10% that's what I
see a lot of the times and so it's an
outrageous valuation when compared to
the average and probably the founders
are getting a 5 X 10 X premium on their
previous experience for good reason you
know they're gonna get the product to
market they've done it many times before
yeah it's just interesting how 10
million versus 250 million right it is
just such a wide gap it's huge and it's
the problem with raising that amount of
money I've seen it happen in later
stages is the whole team gets off their
game entitlement goes off the charts and
you have so much money
you basically drowned an opportunity it
would be the equivalent of like putting
a chef in a Costco or something you know
like a giant warehouse and saying turn
it into a restaurant and it's like ok
where do I even begin you know like
there's every single food item in here
it's just too much it's too overwhelming
to go that big that fast and you it
distances the core team from reality so
much and reality is the customer that
they start arguing over things like
chairs or the receptionist's desk or
where the office is located or what the
laptops are and you know how many gigs
of RAM they have whereas in a regular
company you're like holy [ __ ] we're
almost out of money whoo we better get
this product to market and you need to
have constraint to be a great artist
actually a better analogy than the chef
would be just imagine you gave an artist
a canvas the size of like a giant mural
you know like the side of a building and
you just gave them you know giant you
know oil containers truck your milk
trucks of paint and you're like go ahead
they're like a little bit of a big
canvas here you know what do I even get
started that's why I like constraint
makes great art Bob Dylan said like
they're like hey you know why did this
album come out why did you make the
album he's like why I owed it to the
record label and people are like oh
that's completely disappointing as a
dancer so I kept my back was against the
wall I had to get it out I couldn't
delay the record label anymore so I
you know get my term-paper in and this
bob dylan's case it was the album and it
feels like now the tools are available
where people can create products so
inexpensively and so quickly that they
can get something it maybe not even
fully into the market but to hand you
that it's almost unexplainable unless
you're working on something that's a
really hard tech problem why they don't
why would you go raise money before that
right this is such a great insight pump
because I deal with founders all day
along who tell me if you give me a
hundred thousand dollars or two hundred
fifty thousand dollars I can build this
and then I say you know that's great and
I'm flattered that you're contacting me
I have a long list of people who have
already created stuff and who have a
hundred or a thousand users who are
asking me for 250k at the same valuation
why would I pick you over them and like
well I have great potential make you're
telling me that they're showing me that
and and really that's what I think a lot
of young entrepreneurs don't understand
is the the the people would get funded
in today's market because of what you're
saying it's so cheap to build if you
wanted to build Clubhouse or if you
wanted to build a podcasting app or
whatever it is you can build it in a
weekend sweat equity to three people you
don't need all that money and so you've
basically signaled to the market that
you are a permission asker you're
somebody who needs permission or
validation in order to build whereas
other people there they're gonna make
their album they're gonna tell jokes if
they're a comedian they're gonna make a
short film if they're if you know
they're gonna write their screenplay
they don't need permission to do it
right and that's where founders get
tripped up a lot is that they asked for
you know they're looking for some
validation from an investor you know and
really they should look at the investor
as somewhere between a checkbook or ATM
and a coach or you know a close friend
who can give them candid feedback right
that's really what you're getting when
you're getting an angel or seed investor
somebody who can be candid with you with
advice maybe introduce you to people
just be a good friend and on the margins
a little bit of money to spend on
marketing or hiring that third developer
but you really want to be a developer
which is why Combinator says you have to
have a technologist on your team
you need to have a developer a designer
somebody who could actually build and if
you can't build well what's your goddamn
excuse like go on YouTube and type in
how to build a website how to write code
and people like oh you know that's
ridiculous it's not actually ridiculous
there's free code Campo org I had them
on the podcast we made a small
investment in lambda school
there's lambda school if you want to pay
money and you could do it on the comm
right you don't have to actually pay
them upfront you can pay it on
contingency with an I is a income
sharing agreement so I say is a it's
like so much interesting stuff out there
you really have no excuse well and I
think part of what we've seen happen at
least over the last three or four years
is you know you had way more experience
kind of early 2010s when people were
just fairing it out they're trying to
build companies and the game of Silicon
Valley wasn't yet identified and kind of
popularized across all these media
platforms now literally you'll get
people who pitch you and it's just like
I know what you're doing I know you read
a blog post that's supposed to send this
email or you're supposed to do this I
don't believe you what it's literally
big it used to be opaque and you had to
figure it out like that was the game you
had to figure out what a term sheet was
you had to figure out you know how to
get a lawyer in Silicon Valley you
needed to had to figure out how to get
an office space or a lease or you know
all this stuff was like the first year
was just figuring out the blocking and
tackling and now you can just go onto a
website trademark incorporate set up a
cap table all in a day and get a we
workspace if you feel the need to have
an office in an address and it's all
done in a day for a thousand dollars or
something so you're exactly right and
it's actually I've had this blowback
because I've been doing the podcast for
so long and unpacking entrepreneurship
people pitch me and they know better
what I'm looking for than I do because I
don't remember all the things I've said
in all the advice I've given over a
thousand episodes so they're like they
literally know you need to have the
problem be personal because Garrett camp
and Travis couldn't find a cab in Paris
so they created Ober so they come up
with some fictional story of you know Oh
this itch I had to scratch I had this
frustration in the world and I've had
people who are like I'd literally had
somebody who's like my dog got killed
because he got hit by a car and I'm
making something to protect against that
and I was just like oh my god like there
and it was true in this case but
literally that making something personal
as one example of how to unpack startups
and pitch them is there so then what's
left what's left is actually traction so
I've changed my game all the things
people know I'm gonna ask that's fine
but you know the secret weapon is to
just talk to the customers right you
talk to the customers they is very hard
to fake customers people can there are
techniques to fake customers but we know
them and we figured them out yeah and it
feels like the reduction of friction is
a net positive right it's better that
people can get started faster they can
get office space whatever but there's
just like this level of authenticity and
you almost can smell when somebody's
pitching you what they want they think
you want to hear rather than just doing
it 100 so it's pretty interesting well
think about like a sport like golf or
tennis like to just even understand how
the scoring works in tennis or how to
get a tennis court or how to you know
get a tee a tee time right like these
are very hard things to do if you're
wondering why you don't see a large
number of people doing those sports or
skiing and you don't see diversity in
those sports it might be because it's
really hard to even get started whereas
you know playing baseball or basketball
you know it's really all out there like
all you need is a basketball you know in
a hoop like there's it's accessible to
people and I think that's why the NBA
wound up winning and became such an
amazing sport is because people in China
or Africa or Europe who wanted to play
just needed a basketball you see all
these videos of them playing with like a
bucket pinned against the side of a wall
but they've got a basketball and that's
why I think the NBA became the world's
sport right and soccer as well because
it's just so accessible you just need to
have a soccer ball in a field yeah
absolutely
what uh what else you got oh yeah so
explain to me why aetherium was able to
do essentially a token offering and I
see oh if it
would be considered that but they did a
token offering and they did not get in
trouble with the SEC but other people
did I've never understood this and the
times I've accepted people got very
defensive on the social media on the
Twitter like because I think where
people are concerned because they
probably made a lot of money off of
doing it and I had people in the
industry who are like a pump the brakes
on that you know your friends are in
that you know so what why is that not
considered an IC o---- didn't they sell
all that and take all that money
so obviously I'm not a lawyer I'm gonna
give you my lame my layman's
understanding of where regulators came
out on this yeah and it really it really
comes down to the decentralization of an
existing network before or after the
sale so there's some people who fell in
a category of hey Jason give me money
I'm gonna go build this product and at
some point in the future I will launch
it and that will be decentralized
regulators have said no you're
essentially raising capital right you're
taking money and that is going to be
considered some sort of security and
you'll get in trouble if you didn't do
everything you supposed to do in the
case of an aetherium what it sounds like
is regulators said look aetherium we are
not gonna make a decision on the time at
which they did their token sale so
actually the regulators have not said
whether that was quote-unquote legal or
not but at this point it is
decentralized enough where it is not
going to be deemed a security today god
it's a part of the the big question
there is something that previously
hasn't been an option is can you
actually have a security that's offered
that then transitions to a non security
so in the case of aetherium was it a
security when it was sold but then once
the network is built and decentralized
could it transition to now because
they're not a security
it sounds like regulators are open to
that idea I'm not by any means well
versed enough to kind of tell them where
they're gonna come out on that but but
it is interesting because that's
something that doesn't exist in
traditional companies it seems to be
like it's a it's the SEC is doing a
reasonable job at balancing innovation
and protecting consumers from scams
would you agree with that or do you
think that they've been slow I think
that they've been slow which means that
they've been doing a good job right so
both of those things are true God what I
mean by that is nobody knows right like
I mean literally people are
experimenting and so naturally
regulators are gonna be slower than the
innovators but there's some things that
are just outright scams so if I say
Jason give me a hundred thousand dollars
you know I've got this great product you
give me the money and then it comes out
that I didn't have the product right
like okay that's just a scam and I ran
off with the money
like everyone agrees that's a bad thing
you know go after those people so I
think that they've done a pretty good
job given how tough the situation is
there's plenty of people that wish that
they would come out with more clear
guidance and all this stuff they just
don't know right and so I think that
it's gonna take time to get clearer
guidance one thing that I didn't
understand that they didn't do and I'm
wondering what you think of my idea
which is in the world I live in when we
do what's called a special purpose
vehicle at the syndicate calm or
angellist does it or seedinvest or other
places that do sp V's this is they said
you can have 250 people but you're
capped out at ten million dollars per
investment and somebody's got to be on
the hook for managing all this and that
happens to me me in this case the
syndicate lead and they have to all be
accredited investors so there was kind
of a you know and if you have a hundred
people you're not capped at the 250 so
they they were basically trying I think
that's the I think I got a right and
people can look it up and correct me if
I'm wrong but ballpark what they said
was let's make if there is a crater if
this thing does blow up let's make it
not create huge collateral damage right
what I would have done if I was the SEC
is I would have said anybody who
registers at this website sec.gov slash
crypto if you register your project here
you can go through a quick registration
process which says you can have any
number of investors capped at a million
dollars you can have up to five million
dollars capped at this number and ten
million at this number and as long as
your project stays within those bounds
you're good for
five years and if you want to go above
that then you got to kick into
securities mode or whatever it is so you
can read it I don't know what the number
is but it seems to me that if a bunch of
people are limited to non-accredited
investors are limited to $1,000 each
well what's the harm there you know like
even if they were paid minimum wage they
could get out of that hole in a hundred
hours of work right it wouldn't be what
we call in poker and gambling the risk
of ruin which is playing with your
entire chip stack in one game and you
get a bad beat and somebody hit squads
against your you know boat and you you
you lose it all so what what do you
think of that kind of approach and do
other people take that approach in other
jurisdictions I don't know the the
global jurisdiction reality these days
yeah so the first thing that I'll say is
people have to remember venture
capitalists are professionals right
you've got funds I've got funds
everyone's got a fund and our job is
literally to take limited partners
capital and go find the best deals that
we can possibly find they're going to
drive a return so that is the day job of
these investors and so naturally they're
gonna find quote-unquote the best
companies and projects do they miss
sometimes absolutely right so there's
definitely some selection bias for
people who choose not to go that path
doesn't mean it's for everybody but for
sure I think that's kind of we have to
remember that that's why venture capital
exists for projects that want to grow
very big now there is a subset of
companies that have chosen to go through
something like let's call reggae plus
and again I don't know all of the
details but as far as like there's any
IPO basically they have to do a little
bit more and you can raise like up to
like I think it's a million point oh
seven dollars or something right so
there is some things that are kind of
trending in the direction you're talking
about but the reason why I brought up
the venture capital model to begin with
is it's actually less of a headache for
the entrepreneur to go pay if you have a
good product right and you're believable
in the sense that you can actually go
execute what your plan is it's easier
just to go pitch the venture capitalist
to raise the money than it is to go and
do jump through all these hoops to use
reggae plus or do an ICO where do all
saw the crazy stuff yeah and what that
does is it sends the best deal flow to
the most
qualify people who have the biggest chip
stacks and it sends what should be on
average the weaker deal flow the deal
flow that VCS didn't buy into now again
you said perfectly that they may not
always get it right but maybe they get
it right two out of three times which
means that deal flow that makes it to
these other sites might be you know the
apples at the bottom of the bushel let's
say maybe they couldn't clear market
maybe the return profile is different
than them and and that works actually
against the spirit of the law which is
you're you're trying to make this more
equal and fair and so the unintended
consequence is troubling and the other
thing I'll say too is if you talk to
younger entrepreneurs first-time
entrepreneurs the one thing I've noticed
is there's a lot of focus on the
economics of the deal right they want to
squeeze out every last economic
advantage that they can and so they're
constantly trying to optimize for the
highest valuation that you know the most
money raised all kind of stuff if you go
talk to serial entrepreneurs and things
like that the numbers are important
right they're not gonna give away the
company but who they partner with is way
more important they understand that the
100's sure can can move the company can
introduce them to customers can do all
the things that they need help with and
so I do think also what you get is you
get some selection bias of if you want
to take money from retail investors at
the highest possible valuation is that
entrepreneur the same entrepreneur that
can walk into the best you know Sandhill
venture capital fund and raise from
those investors I don't know maybe in
some cases yes but my guess is that more
times than not it's not that type of
event I've literally had people in the
industry let's just say another
accelerator that maybe the launch
accelerator competes with I've heard
stories of people saying you explicitly
don't want sophisticated investors in
your first round and advise founders to
go after the dumb money that will not
read the documents that will pay the
highest price and that will have no
governance concerns and that you can
roll over in later rounds so literally
there's a group of people in Silicon
Valley who would be advising startups to
go to the dentists to go to the naive
investors and say if you're gonna raise
the million dollars instead of doing
500k from
you know a lien Liat you know cowboy
ventures or hunter and satya from
homebrew instead of getting those
sophisticated folks who are gonna want
good provisions protective provisions
proper governance yeah screw it just
just pass the Hat and do what's called a
party round in our industry and so that
is you know you may not see this out on
the East Coast but I see it out here
where people actually do that as a
strategy like literally to try to get
the dumb money to have less controls and
you know what they wind up regretting it
I mean the founders do because you want
the smartest people on your teams and
the incremental 20% on valuation when
your company does have trouble and the
most skin somebody has in the game is
50k versus somebody like Aileen Lee who
might have 500k in or I have 500k in
we're gonna go to war with you we're
gonna try to solve the problem the
personally 50k is a dentist is like yep
got to do like one more set of veneers
and I'm good I can make that money back
you know just over charge somebody for
veneers and you're done well one of the
frameworks I really like is you can
optimize for the economic advantage that
you get out of a fundraising round or
you can optimize for the intellectual
advantage and again it just goes back to
this idea of like you want the smartest
people and the most experienced people
running into the fire with you right
kind of your point of like hey if deaf
matter Wester knows what they're doing
like that's who you actually want and so
giving up 1% more 10% more whatever the
number is they those investors if they
are actually good will make that back
for you you know tenfold later on down
the road let me ask you a question about
you know we were debating you and I
having a fun time on the Twitter talking
about like all the speculation in crypto
and you know you'd come at me about like
hey what about thorough notes and the
outliers great now and people love to
gamble
we have Wall Street bets we have Robin
Hood day traders and full disclosure I
was an early investor in the in Robin
Hood and it's probably my third big
right now on paper might be the third
biggest return I have
after uber and calm and that's really
not a disclosure as much as a flex to be
clear but they had three million people
I think during the pandemic ahead and
Wall Street bats is going crazy El
Presidente from Portnoy is going crazy
okay so we have crazy speculation crypto
crazy speculation and startups and now
we have crazy speculation coming to the
public markets what do you take from
what's happening at this very moment
any general hot takes or observations
about what's going on and that little
crevice of Reddit three things one
anyone who thinks that Dave Portnoy is
not performing and entertaining and
creating media content they're confused
as to what he's doing he's the best in
the world at it right and that's not a
knock against him at all actually it's a
complete tip of the cap of he has
literally gone from this guy who ran a
sports site that was highly successful
450 million dollar valuation and on
literally the flip of a coin pivoted
into an industry that prides itself on
the suits and ties and you know the the
Wall Street finance all this kind of
stuff and he's just taking it by storm
I mean they've every can't avoid talking
about right like he is dominating
headlines and so I think that when I see
what he's doing when it's incredible but
to he's not doing it from I just trying
to make money he's obviously got larger
kind of entertainment driven ambitions
which which is important to remember too
is on the Robin Hood traders and kind of
the retail speculation it's all the same
like everything you just mentioned from
icos to sports gambling to public
marketing gambling everyone is chasing
easy money
right and what you can quickly identify
is what's the strategy and literally
people will tell you kind of all kinds
of crazy stuff in the ico boom they'll
tell you all kinds of crazy stuff right
now but if you've been around and paying
attention like buying a bankrupt stock
and having you know a hundred fifty
thousand people owning Hertz stock after
the bankruptcy it's kind of just like
okay that's where we are
like sure yeah it makes no sense
and the people that hurts it makes no
sense to them either but if you are
looking at it as gambling and
entertainment it makes total sense
because people are just doing this like
they might bet on the Knicks to you know
beat the spread
they know they're gonna get demolished
by you know whatever team LeBron decides
to be on you know for this next three or
sprint we know we're gonna get crushed
it's just a matter of do we even can I
entertain myself during being crushed
like that I mean I think Dave is just
amazing at you know entertaining people
I mean he literally makes eating a slice
of pizza entertaining and he understands
who he is as a character which is
obnoxious and successful and does not
care about anybody's opinion he's like
the classic ENTJ
you know if we to use you know
horoscopes for men the myers-briggs he's
like that classic ENTJ leader I know
better than everybody I'm obnoxious I
don't care about your opinion and I'll
tell you what the pizza is it's a seven
point - it's an eight point - and it's
kind of fun to watch but yeah it's not
serious the thing I love about it I
think there's something great about this
because when I invested in Robin Hood
Vlad and his partner walked up to me in
a bar called Antonio's nuthouse and they
said you're Jason Calacanis I said tell
me about your startup he said how do you
know we have a startup is it you
recognized me right this is the ultimate
tip-off like I'm not famous I'm only
famous with founders and he said we want
to create a trading platform for
Millennials on their phones and I said
let me stop you right there you do know
that they're on their parents Netflix
accounts they will not buy a car they
only take lyft and uber and these are
the most commitment-phobic people in the
world there they will not sign a lease
and you want them to buy stocks for a
future 50 years from now when they're
retired it's just not gonna happen like
and by the way all retail investors went
away after 2008 and the dot-com bust
like we've demolished them twice in
recent memory and they said but Jason
that's the opportunity what if we do and
I was like that's the right answer
actually is it all right fine tell me
how you make my
and they said well that's the that's the
kicker we're gonna make it free okay I'm
in like this this makes total sense to
me right and it makes no sense in one
way but if you're saying if it does work
and it's a long shot what happens to the
world and I just said what if they get a
million people doing this and now here
they are with 13 if all these kids are
taking their money for they would have
bet on sports in the NFL and the NBA and
they're just putting it into stocks well
I think they got a better chance of
winning and they're gonna learn about
finance I mean my kids know more I've
never done a put or I've never done like
puts and calls and shorted stocks I've
never done any of that stuff I buy Sokka
hold until I don't like it any more than
I sell it I'm not buying futures raises
but you know my my nephew
you know director Nick over here he he's
explaining to me calls and puts and how
to use Robin and I'm like III don't have
any I just want to buy goober and hold
it for 20 years
like that's it so I think that that's
the silver lining which in a way is what
the crypto speculation did as well which
is in order to speculate encrypt out you
at least I have to get a wallet so you
have to know that you have to know your
hash you gotta know your password you
got to know all this stuff right well
I'll take it a step further
right and you respond to this how you
want but what you just described about
low probability but high potential of
Robin Hood when they put you on that
yeah is I think exactly why people are
so excited about Bitcoin because right
now maybe people would say you know five
years ago the potential for Bitcoin to
reach I'll say global reserve status
right less than 1% now I don't know
maybe worth three to five percent right
still incredibly low odds but if it gets
there you're talking about an asset
that's you know one hundred fifty two
hundred billion dollars in value that
would eventually get into the tens of
trillions of dollars so there's a
hundred X from here Oh easy I mean right
just look at the look at the global
monetary supply right so a hundred x
from here is only fifteen trillion and I
think global money supply is you know in
the 70 80 trillion dollar range are
already talking about for 500 X the
thing
super fascinating about also barstool
and I'll just wrap that up is I think
he's creating barstool finance so you
know you have financed out yahoo.com
he's just creating bars to finance and
so you know he's got sports
he's got finance I think with call her
daddy he's got kind of his own love line
or romance or sex kind of property like
what else is a property that Yahoo had
back in the day movies and entertainment
so does bar still do movies and
entertainment yet no but he'll back some
movie at some point and be a producer or
a director and he'll be like I'm gonna
be a producer of movies I'm giving money
to these movies and then those movies
will actually work you'll love this
so March 31st 2017 this is right after
Peter Chernin
and and his team bought a little over
50% of barstool for about 78 million
dollars right I wrote a blog post that
said this is going to be a billion
dollar company and at the time people
are like you're nuts all stuff and I
laid out you know here's what I think
happens and one of the key points was
they're gonna get outside of sports and
I didn't know if those politics or news
or kind of how they would do it but I
think you're dead-on in that once you
have the attention of the audience it's
very easy just to add another
personality that touches in a new area
right so whether that's finance whatever
it what I do wonder about barstool is
they they have been a very
non-traditional media company for a long
time right in terms of the way that
they've built it it's highly profitable
all those kind of stuff but they sold a
third of it to this gaming company Penn
National which on the face looks super
interesting now Penn National's kind of
got this great marketing arm through bar
stool bar stools got exposure to the
public markets all that kind of stuff
but what I do wonder is would they have
been better off if they were the ones
buying a gaming company 100% yeah yeah I
mean that's probably just Dave doesn't
have a ton of experience you know in big
business and he's just got this asset
and he just wanted to cash his chips in
and mission accomplished you got a
hundred million dollars right in that
but but he didn't cash in so to his
credit this is what this was pretty
crazy is he a hundred million dollars I
think he took more than half of it in
stock smart so he so he
he still is betting on himself I think
but but the whole model of just as you
look around businesses right this one
kind of gets into just early-stage
companies today they used to build the
product and you would invest and then
they would go try to find customers
right right and that's that's the risk
you were taking was kind of can they
find the customers what I do see more
and more companies starting to do now is
they go build the audience and then they
say hey I already have the customers now
I'm gonna build products for them Yeah
right and that did that I mean that was
like instagrams like hey we're a tool
for making photos look better and now
you know they finally are they've turned
on the ability to buy stuff inside of
Instagram like it's literally an Amazon
competitor a facebook advertising
competitor so it's going up against
Google and Facebook for ads and now it's
going up against Shopify or they're in
partnership with Shopify they'll
eventually try to kill Shopify because
that's what Zuckerberg does you slit the
throat of anybody he partners with so
Toby if you're listening you know you
know I worked at Facebook so I'm biased
are you telling me he's not the most
cutthroat person in business name
somebody more cutthroat than Mark
Zuckerberg and how he approaches
competition if you had to pick Mark
Zuckerberg or Jeff Bezos who's more
cutthroat yeah I got to go with
Zuckerberg and I'll give you my
rationale yeah it's it it's because he
has absolutely no moral compass when it
comes to stealing other people's
innovations and he literally does not
care what anybody thinks about him so he
told the Instagram the whatsapp founders
hey just copy snapchat just do exactly
what Evan Spiegel is doing just copy it
do not even think for yourself and you
know that's all on the record and I
don't think Bezos thinks like that I
think Bezos wants to think like hey it's
day zero let's really think about this
product how would we do it he's not
looking basis isn't looking at the
competitors and saying whatever
innovation they do go do it and kill
them maybe on the margins for Amazon Web
Services they do that they look for you
know Twilio or something and try to
compete but I just think no but sneaker
Berger has a throat miss that is just
unbelievable so the one thing that I
will say is I think that those two
generalizations are probably more
than not and the Zuckerberg stuff you
know I'm not gonna change your mind on
that but like if you take Bezos for
example like didn't he with diapers.com
all these things like he basically would
go to them and say hey you're March is
my opportunity
yeah I'm literally gonna sell items at a
loss and try to run you off the you know
the competitive field and then when
you're literally bleeding out you'll
come to me and I'll buy you for you know
pennies on the dollar
I think that's implied yes I think that
is implied I think that's the that is
and this is actually an interesting
discussion for us just to have to take
it away from the personal because I
if you told me who are the two most
cutthroat people I would have picked
them and just in a different order than
you you probably would say Bezos then
Zuckerberg you got anybody else you'd
put in there it as garrier to go up
against me yeah I would say at least out
of the people who run big businesses
those are the two yeah let me know by
the way it's gonna come in and do Apple
would never do what know something Apple
might have their own interesting
anti-competitive approaches but they
would never do what Zuckerberg would do
it's snapchat right which is we're gonna
copy that product until we kill the
company and just keep going on it what I
think is really interesting about Amazon
and I'd love to hear your thoughts on it
is do you think Amazon should be stopped
from creating Amazon basic products and
why
meaning what do you feel that
anti-competitive people are now there's
investigations going on with regulators
in the United States and in the EU
around this concept of Bezos and the
Amazon team study what's selling from
third-party sellers who are half of the
I think at roughly half of what's sold
on Amazon and if you make some great
amazing charging you know power strip
they're gonna make an Amazon basics one
should they be should the government
interfere and stop Amazon from both
selling third-party and creating their
own products or not and why I think
that's the wrong trade-off to look at I
don't think the problem is that they
make a competing product I think it's
when they promote their competing
product above yours in the search
results or they take away your
distribution and hurt you in exchange
for promoting their own okay so that is
you like Google does with their search
box right they movie up down and they
put Google Local yeah literally if
you're the third-party reseller on face
or on Amazon and I'm Amazon and I see
that you're you know you're selling
microphones and they're doing really
well and I go make my own and I put it
into the marketplace and we're on
complete completely equal footing so I
get no advantage in the search rankings
all that stuff I don't think that's as
big of a problem I think where did they
get kind of in the murky water and
people get really upset and probably
where they end up getting in trouble is
if then I say hey Jason I'm no longer
gonna send you traffic I'm gonna promote
my my phone above yours right now all of
a sudden you're you're playing a
different game
so is the issue and this is where Google
got away with it because Google had Matt
Cutts who was in charge of search spam
or whatever go out and live for them
over and over again where he said we
have not changed the organic search
results and he's such a liar and so who
in San Siro was incredible he said and
while that is true they moved the first
organic search result 400
goes down the page and put a box at the
top for shopping a box at the top for
travel a box at the top for your stocks
a box at the top for of course Google
Local so they're they're so smart right
and they're Matt's such a clever guy
that they had convinced themselves that
they were not just absolutely lying and
evil and what they did was they moved
everything down 400 pixels so it's below
the fold and then put their widget up
top and this is why you know they really
had a chance of getting sanctioned
because they did exactly what you're
saying which is gave preferential
treatment to themselves but they said oh
no no no no we didn't change organic
search organic search is the same it's
like yeah but if you everybody knows 90
percent of the clicks are above the fold
the first 100 pixels 90 percent of the
clicks then they moved it down Amazon is
not doing that the thing they actually
have concerns about Amazon is that
they're studying which products are
selling well and then creating products
like those which by the way Amazon puts
that in form this is why I think Amazon
I would argue Amazon shouldn't be
stopped from doing this I agree with you
they shouldn't get preferential
treatment if you're powershred if you're
a microphone if you're a podcast
microphone pumps podcast microphones are
better selling and better reviews they
should go up in the search and Amazon
should go down I agree on that the
people think that they're using the data
to pick which products well I don't have
a problem with them doing that either if
that data is also shared universally
because they have it for the public
right you can see the reviews all the
reviews are right there I'll even go a
step further I don't want to say that
the companies because I don't know if
this is known or not but there's
literally a business that's based in New
York their whole model was they would go
hit the api's they would pull the search
traffic and basically what they were
looking for was items that had big
margins that were not owned by one
single product hmm and where they felt
like they could get the supply chain so
these are physical products that they
could build the supply chain quickly and
then they would because they're
technologists
figure out how to win that search term
on Amazon so thinking of Amazon is
as a search engine and they had 50 7500
products whatever it was yeah but it
when you saw it it's like look that's
what Amazon is doing so like the fact
that a third party could use data in a
similar manner yeah very good as long as
there's not preferential treatment and I
promise it what do you what do you think
about the Apple what do you think the
Apple and hey well that's a good email
thing so just to put a pin in the or
just just to wrap up the the Amazon one
I think we always have to think about
what's good for Humanity in society it's
pretty great for society that you can
buy a $4 lightning charging cable that
goes to USBC from Amazon basics as
opposed to giving Apple $30 right and so
of course it's just as you lower the
price of goods people's lifestyle goes
up even if and this is the problem I
think we have as a society with how
people perceive how they're doing
everybody sees Bezos or whoever having a
private chat a private island whatever
it is that's just seems so otherworldly
that it makes you feel small but as your
dollar goes further even if your wages
were stagnant
if dollars go further in other words you
can stay in an Airbnb for 50 bucks in
Kyoto or Tokyo a person who is a barista
who could never in their life ever
imagine going to Tokyo on vacation well
now their hotel is you know $500 for 10
days they can actually conceive of it
whereas they previously would have been
in for three four five thousand dollars
so it's an important thing for society
that we actually have rabid capitalism
like how amazing is it that there is
that company that's studying where can
we lower prices massively and take over
a search term like that's good for
consumers in terms of the hakam good
real quick on that so there's this guy
there's this guy Jeff Booth who should
be on the podcasts his whole he wrote a
book on the idea of technology being
deflationary yeah and the fact that
actually the capitalism in the
competition ends up over long periods of
time driving prices
yeah which is a net good for society
right exactly what you're talking about
the fact that being driven somewhere in
a car used to be only for the elite to
be driven somewhere to show up and get
out of the backseat of a car was you
know like there were cabs but you know
to get out of the back of a car and have
a private driver was like oh you must be
really wealthy and live on the Upper
East Side somewhere in a townhouse and
then it's like no I I work at you know
McDonald's and I'm taking an uber and
and so where's a lyft line and I got two
other people in the car getting a
point-to-point driver even to come to
your house and wait for you outside is
incredible win and if you I remember
that my neighbor when I was in Bay Ridge
Brooklyn bought a Mercedes at some point
with a cup with a sunroof and he would
take us for a ride and over the
Verrazano Bridge and let all the kids
stand up and stick their heads out
though some the sunroof it was like
something from Mad Men but I was just
amazed at the power windows and that he
had like this incredible cassette tape
and it had air conditioning and I just
think like power windows like you can't
buy a car without power windows like all
of these things are just standard now
because of the the power of capitalism
but it really is an interesting thing
with Hakam if you look at the reason why
Apple wants to control the ecosystem is
because they want to preserve and I and
I actually do believe this it's not just
to put a 30% tax on everything they want
to preserve the quality of that phone by
having things go through an approval
process you increase the quality of the
phone and you'll have less spyware
you'll have less crashes and overall the
the product will trend towards a better
user experience because there's
uniformity now if there were five app
stores you could get lower prices you
could get crazier stuff but you get your
phone hacked and you could also have
your phone crashing and need to be
rebooted which by the way is what
happened on the Windows operating system
for a long time and happens on Android
if you're on Android the chance of you
getting hit with spyware and I think
Android now has like a preferred partner
program or something where they actually
review stuff
the review process was always intended
to make things work better but it was
also used for nefarious reasons like you
couldn't have a third-party browser in
the beginning you couldn't have a
third-party video player and now you can
get those things so even Apple knows
they can't overplay their hand and what
they've run into with you know Jason and
DHH over at Basecamp over at 37signals
with this new product hakam which is
just you know I actually started using
it today it's kind of a clunky looking
email client it's not very good looking
it's got a great domain name and it has
really one killer feature which is the
first time somebody asks you to his
first time somebody shows up in your
inbox they put them in the screener just
like you might screen a phone call and
then you decide should this person be
allowed to email me or not and you give
them a thumbs up or thumbs down so for
somebody like me it was a super router
that's just a killer feature
so we're investors in super-human and I
was I told the superhuman team like this
is the feature this is the killer
feature of hey it needs to be in super
human yesterday and it needs your Lord
Zuckerberg absolutely
no I mean it's just a feature of that of
that platform but it is a really killer
feature that people do need to pay
attention to but the 30 percent tax is
reasonable if you compared it to selling
something in Amazon or selling something
in a store right what's the markup in
retail so when people used to put
software in retail the retailer would
get half the money right you'd give them
Photoshop or you know some video game
Chessmaster for $50 they'd sell it for
50 the store got 25 they got 25 so that
needs to be 50% markup so 30% reasonable
unless it's subscriptions and then it
becomes meaningful so they dropped I
think the second year subscription goes
down to 15% so people renew you pay 30%
on the first year subscription 15 so
what I tell my startups is pay the Vig
to Apple if you play nice with Apple and
you let them make money from it they can
invest in the App Store and then they
might promote you or they might write a
feature about you
etc so calm calm you know has people pay
for subscriptions in the app store and
if you do that then you're on the paid
ranking list as well which is why they
have a list of the top paying top
revenue generating apps if you don't and
like Netflix and Spotify no longer allow
you to subscribe to the App Store you
subscribe on their website and then you
go there that's actually an interesting
you know debate but I think people
should be allowed to make that decision
for themselves
the app providers like Netflix and
Spotify had half yeah again everyone
should just be treated the same so if
you're going to say hey anybody who you
want to sign up off the App Store and
they're gonna pay you there we're not
gonna take anything okay fine if they
pay in the app through the App Store
we're gonna take a piece of it okay fine
I think where it gets kind of again
little gray area is when you say we're
gonna treat you one way but Netflix does
the exact same thing they get treated at
a different way and I just keep reading
to DHH for knowing that this would
happen and then creating a brouhaha and
he was on CNBC today and SIA but I saw
him tweet about it
I mean he's just so good at fighting
every time he comes on the podcast it's
like a double trip oh I don't have you
had DHH on the pod yet I haven't
come on your pod it he's he's good
Austin from lambda said literally this
is the chapter out of their book and
then he screenshot it's like chapter six
of rework and they talk all about
I don't literally pick yeah pick an
enemy right that's bigger than you make
a big stink how people pay attention so
what I do think is interesting is do you
think it was intentional that they pick
100 100 100 oh really
yeah I know he and he had pre picked the
fight with superhuman because superhuman
has the tracking pixel that tells you if
people opened it and when they opened it
you know just like every other piece of
software has every Gmail plugin has
outlook as but he's made that like oh
we're gonna stop the evil superhuman
from you know you know tracking you and
yeah here's the quote actually from
Austin it's literally a chapter out of
their book having an enemy gives you a
great story to tell customers to taking
a stand always stands out people get
stoked by conflict they take
sides passions are ignited and that's a
good way to get people to take notice
and you know it's I have them on my
pockets just so we can debate venture
capital versus not venture capital you
know and in fact us having a debate
about crypto or not crypto the fact that
we largely agree now just kills our
ratings I mean if we were at each
other's throats and do so much better
but he said you have you bought bitcoins
as last time I was on you know I had
bought Bitcoin when it was in the early
very early the whatever ten bitcoins I
had got hacked because the back then
there were no exchanges really there was
no you know there weren't a lot of
exchanges so that got hacked and I
probably lost ten bitcoins and then my
wife had bought a bunch when it was at
$300 or $800 so we're massively up on
that I haven't bought more and the and
I've actually thought about just putting
one percent of my net worth into Bitcoin
because of the hedge you talk about the
thing I've been impressed about and has
evolved my thinking on Bitcoin is that
it has not been hacked or had like you
know a 51% attack or any way I know it's
been manipulated I know it's anonymous
or pseudo anonymous so there's all these
you know edge cases but the fact that a
government hasn't been able to either
shut it down or you know hack it
explicitly I know they can hack you know
your wallet or hack coinbase or spoof
you but the fact that the core has not
been compromised to me is just
extraordinary why there's so much at
stake in hacking Bitcoin the fact that
it hasn't been act to me is phenomenal
it's the number one target in the world
correct so I would separate us in two
pieces one is there is an argument that
hacking the actual protocol itself would
ruin all the value right so the second
that sanity goes in hacks it like the
two hundred billion dollars of market
value goes to zero right because it's no
longer
unhackable but with that said I've had a
lot of success talking especially the
institutional investors about this but I
think a lot of Technology investors get
it as well
so if I said to you hey I want to own
part of Google's search algorithm right
you would say go buy Google stock if I
said to you I want to own Facebook
social network
you'd say go buy Facebook stock correct
if I said to you I want to own the
strongest computing network in the world
which is the Bitcoin network you would
say go buy but there's no corporation to
go by there's no equity and so what you
have to do to get financial exposure is
you have to buy Bitcoin itself right and
so part of what I think is really
interesting here is there was a very
long period of time where maybe a couple
people in Silicon Valley were into this
but really for the most part a lot of
people missed Bitcoin in terms of the
amount of capital that could have been
put into it Bryce young people got
personal exposure whatever but when you
think of it it's just the strongest
computing network in the world and I ask
people like what's that worth I don't
think you and I are gonna be good at
putting a future value on that but if it
remains the strongest competing network
in the world I think it's worth
trillions of dollars at a minimum right
and so to put some exposure into it I
think just is generally a good practice
yeah my thesis was this is the what I
came to and over the last couple of
years since it did not get hacked and
it's still stable I said to my and we
had people on this podcast talking about
Bitcoin when it was under $1 so just to
be clear I mean I've been tracking this
forever my belief the last couple years
has been majority chance as it goes down
to zero or you know low hundreds of
dollars and gets replaced by a better
technology because that's what always
happens almost universally some
technology gets replaced now there are
some that have not that had become built
to last email as an open protocol has
and the web RSS kind of got deprecated
because Google gave up on reader and so
it doesn't always happen that way and
FTP and gopher and send and all these
Usenet other things that were open
protocols haven't gone away or
just are not used all that often but it
feels you felt to me like the second
somebody made something better than
Bitcoin you know really better and that
also had the increase in value then it
would be game over for Bitcoin because
the people who were holders and were
holding holders they would say you know
what I want to I want to do what I did
with Bitcoin
I want to go 10x I want to go a thousand
X so I'm gonna move my exposure over
here and that would start this you know
degradation of the price right and now
and nobody would buy it because there
was no upside so why hasn't that happen
because I still think that's I would put
that 5050 that that's what happens that
analysis would be dead-on except for one
thing this isn't a technology problem
it's a money thing and so you have to
remember as money as a belief system
like why you why would you take dollars
from me and I take dollars from you
because we both believe that dollar has
value now the best way to highlight the
difference and what you just said and
what I think Bitcoin provides is if
you're in a country where you're
nation-state currency fails like it
literally hyperinflation the whole nine
yards and then the government comes to
you and says hey Jason sorry that that
happened but we got this new currency
that we created just use this one you
are very very unlikely to believe them
on the second one right you they
violated your trust and so when I think
of Bitcoin what I think of is we we
being the citizens of the world get one
shot two separate state money one shot
at it that is Bitcoin
if it happens tens of trillions if not
hundreds of children's of dollars in
value if it doesn't happen Bitcoin goes
to zero and there will not be a
replacement because it has too much
momentum and too much buy-in at this
point it has kind of the the mental kind
of capture this is the shot to separate
state money and so when I think of it
that way it's if Bitcoin was to fail I
actually don't think people would buy
into the next one mentally because it
would say oh you can never separate
state and money right there's too many
people who are seeing this for the first
time and so it's like we get one shot
you know
hey all you speculators that are
speckling in the public market stuff
don't go put a hundred percent of your
assets into Bitcoin but also don't get
caught having zero exposure right I
think that's I think that's a pretty
good analysis actually and maybe I'll
just after this podcast go put 1% into
Bitcoin what what is it wasn't this
supposed as a question I have for you
wasn't a world-changing event a world
shattering event supposed to be the
moment where Bitcoin shined what we just
went through this crazy pandemic that I
think is the definition of that a global
shutdown that like none we've seen and
there was supposed to be this massive
flight into it and then there was this
other reason that you all kept saying
was oh you guys are printing so much
money right money printer goes burr or
whatever that meme you guys have it you
fight your wars and memes which I think
the VC community needs to learn from we
got to get better at me more fair in the
investment committee here in Silicon
Valley but why didn't Bitcoin spike over
the last you know year I mean I know it
was that like 6,000 and went up to
whatever 7 or something or actually
maybe it said nine so shouldn't it have
gone crazy or no so let's go back in
history to understand what's happening
now in 2008 when the financial crisis
hit gold which is widely considered a
store value it went down 30% over the
summer of 2008 and the reason is there's
liquidity crisis so people looked around
their portfolios and said the world's
ending all chaos has broken loose I want
to sell any asset that's got a liquid
market to it and so they sold everything
ready sold stocks they sold gold this
scared people
yeah and so in response to that
liquidity crisis the Federal Reserve
printed at the time hundreds of billions
of dollars right and then gold 2x10
value from there ended up hitting an
all-time high in 2011 what we just saw
so far are still in I would argue is
there was a liquidity crisis starting in
March where people looked around the
room and sold everything right I mean
Bitcoin went down 50% in one day at one
point right
stocks went down 30% gold went down 15%
all stuff but if you look from the
beginning of this year to now Bitcoin is
up 3035 percent it's actually the best
performing asset of all the asset
classes right it's better than most
commodities better than stocks etc and
so what it's doing is its hyper volatile
and the best comparison I think is if
you look at like Amazon right so
Amazon's been one of the best performing
stock since it went public it's gone
down double digits every single year
it's been public and the average intra
year drawdown of Amazon stock is 30 plus
percent one-time it went down over 90
percent in a time period and so when you
look at that Amazon stocks been hyper
volatile but it's also led to incredible
growth a lot of innovation spin-1 best
reformed stocks Bitcoin looks very
similar in the sense that it's hyper
volatile when there's times of liquidity
crisis all assets trend towards a
correlation of one Bitcoin went down but
on the rebound where we see the Federal
Reserve printing all this money Bitcoin
has performed all of their assets and so
if you look at somebody like a Paul
Tudor Jones his argument is look I
believe central banks are gonna continue
to print trillions of dollars and inject
liquidity into the global economy
I want to own what he called the quota
quote the fastest horse and he believes
that to be Bitcoin so he put 2% of his
assets you know a couple hundred million
dollars into Bitcoin and said I think
that this is just gonna help perform
everything else that central bank's just
pump these assets to the moon
when will Bitcoin hit a new all-time
high and under and what would be the
likely scenario that would cause it to
do that so because what was 20,000 yeah
all-time highs a little hard what what I
will say is and I've said publicly a
couple times is in 2017 all of these
kind of models right if you think of how
is price determined its supply and
demand the advantage Bitcoin has over
all other assets is that you know with
100% certainty you can verify how many
Bitcoin exists and how many are coming
in and the daily supply so gold for
example you kind of sort of know how
much exists you kind of sort of know how
much being produced on a daily basis but
with Bitcoin you know 100% fact so
really what you've got to be able to do
is model out or forecast
demand and if bitcoins demand continues
to grow how it has for the last decade
it was supposed to hit $10,000 in
December in 2017 and it's supposed to
hit $100,000 by the end of 2021 in
obviously 2017 we saw it go from ten
thousand over 10,000 to 20,000 dollars
it went from 10,000 to 20,000 in 18 days
in q4 of 2017 yeah that was like the
holidays like Thanksgiving just in
December I remember my wife was like
it's a boy off top yeah it was
incredible and I was like salad
I spoke at that crypto conference out of
the Santa Monica Airport and I said
listen I know a lot of you bought this
nonsense for a hundred bucks and you
tried 20,000 now please so half because
this never happens in the world that you
have a 10x20 acts 200 acts in this
period of time I know you think it's
gonna go 200 X from here please sell
half and buy a house and nobody did it
maybe some people did it I don't know
Mike it had to be somebody on the other
side of the trade right yeah what I
think happens is it once it's twenty
thousand it was there for like I don't
know 24 hours right it's like it hung
out there for a while crash all the way
down to around 3,000 I think what will
happen over the next 18 months is we're
gonna see another massive bull market so
we're gonna see Bitcoin you know go hit
a hundred thousand dollars by the end of
2021 it's gonna be the same thing that
you saw in 2017 there's gonna be mass
chaos people aren't gonna sell they're
gonna be piling in and faux mowing and
doing all the stuff and so what ends up
kind of happening is like look markets
or markets right we've talked about how
many markets today where people FOMO in
and they're speculating so it's just
kind of like you know you can warn
people as much as you want but they're
still gonna speculate right human nature
takes over and greed takes over yeah
well why are people not making purchases
with cryptocurrency
like what is that why did that because
that was everybody seems to think ten
years ago we were buying pizza with
crypto it would be so easy is it just
that the other credit cards and
everything is just too good and there's
no real advantage to paying for stuff in
crypto is it good people don't want to
they want to hold all their crypto let's
you ready yeah who do you think has more
annual volume last year venmo or Bitcoin
on chains not exchanged for in volume
but actually on chain transactions I
have no idea good question I mean but
aren't the transactions are Bitcoin
those include speculation just that's
just people trading Bitcoin back and
forth not buying substance in a store so
not trading on exchanges so that all the
exchange traded volume is not accounted
for here and also it's something called
an adjusted on chain metric so also all
the transactions to and from exchanges
is taken out right so this could be I
could be trading with you more I could
be buying from a merchant but they're
generally much snot a be bit close
you're asking when okay who's the nature
of you asking the question but I am
shocked to hear that it is Bitcoin if it
is who do you think had more annual
volume last year Apple pay or Bitcoin
well Apple pay is brand-new it's got to
be bit going right but I wouldn't I
don't know if I'd say that in ten years
but yeah who do you think had more
annual volume PayPal or Bitcoin last
year I would go a bit I would go PayPal
oh yeah that one
it was Bitcoin huh Wow and so when you
look at that
right I think any of that is Fugazi and
like people are just shipping money
around to paint the tape is the term for
creating volume when we've talked about
this before I think on previous episodes
but painting the tape is occurring or
some automation is occurring to you know
kind of make it seem like these
exchanges are more vibrant than they are
so this is important detail on the
exchanges absolutely that's happening
right all the washed trading all that
stuff is absolutely happening especially
on exchanges outside the United States
the metric I'm specifically referencing
is adjusted on chain transaction volume
so this is I literally sent it to you
right and it doesn't include the
exchange volume which is important
because that's very similar to like
sending venmo
PayPal Apple pay whatever but but I
think look at the end of the day where I
come out on it is I have been shocked at
how global Bitcoin is like we're so
spoiled in the Western world we just
look at what are people doing down the
screw
we forget that you know take Lebanon for
right now I just did a an episode with
with Sunnah from vult capital her
family's lives in Lebanon they're
Lebanese lira has collapsed 75 percent
against the dollar in the last couple of
weeks and so what do they all do they
want dollars they can't get home so the
next best thing is bitcoin Rex the only
need an internet connection so I think
that'll continue to happen over time and
you know again look it's a speculative
very binary outcome for Bitcoin but I
think my message more is just have
exposure to we don't have zero exposure
alright we made it to 70 minutes I know
that you got a lot of questions for me I
got a lot of questions for you let's do
lightning round of the questions alright
ready I get first okay
if you were president you get three days
what are the things you do wow what a
great question I hope you answer it as
well I want to be thoughtful about this
but assuming I could get things done
should I get things done hmm let me
think this through huh well if I could
do an executive order to get rid of
unions police and teachers unions this
is seems to be causing a massive amount
of injustice in the world and there's
there's a really big debate to be had of
what's causing more damage to people of
color in the country the absolute
horrible state of Education or the fact
that people are being murdered for being
you know asleep in a drive-through at
Wendy's and though that is that seems to
me to be something very easy to fix
I think resetting the relationship with
China and demanding that they do things
to help human rights and if not we're
gonna move our changing our dependency
on China is the way I would phrase it
that would be a really good one and then
yeah so there's something about
education and and you know those unions
that I think are the blocker something
about the relationship with China and
that I would also make
I would decrease spending on military
and I would increase spending on
colleges and trade education
specifically and I have been thinking
about reparations and trying to read up
on and understand this issue since we're
talking about a timely issue and it's
very hard to understate there's a big
debate in the in the whole reparations
community and people who are Pro it of
how you would actually execute it and
and how you would give money to people
what if somebody's mixed race did they
get half as much if you know your father
was blogging or mom was wide what how
would you even execute on this I think a
very easy way to do it is to create an
ability for people who have gotten a bad
deal in America a horrible deal and give
them a really great deal for education
trade schools and small business loans
we are really good at spending money in
this country we we can't get masks on
people we can't even get testing going
but we were able to pour money into PPP
at a rate that was just obscene I mean I
was talking to somebody you know and
everybody's got trumped arrangement
syndrome and they hate Trump and I hate
Trump and I considered like the
existential biggest existential risk for
the planet even more than like global
warming is Trump because you know he
could literally start a war and it just
seems to me yeah the whole thing is
super troubling but anyway that it's
something there I said to them you know
you you look at how quickly he got money
to everybody like we can solve for that
but we can't solve
automatic weapons we can't solve
teachers unions we can't solve police
unions we can't solve the college debate
or healthcare but we could ship 500
billions of dollars to the other markets
it's obvious we just need to have the
wherewithal so I also would state that I
think the two-party system needs to be
cracked in this country and I think the
only silver lining I could ever see with
Trump's presidency is that it inspires
people to
get about Republican versus Democrats
and seize a demagogue and he doesn't fit
you know he's destroyed the Republican
Party for all intents and purposes there
might be something there that we could
do to do a crossover ticket I think that
it should be Biden and Condoleezza Rice
you know something like that that brings
America together will you say hey let's
take somebody from the right side let's
take some on the left side and let's try
to meet some in the middle so that's
mine I don't know if you want to answer
that one as well now that you've heard
mine or react to it but I have one for
you I think the two things that jumps
top my head and I should have thought
about this knowing that I was gonna ask
you this a criminal criminal justice
reform that all kinds of nuances in
there but basically like we shouldn't
put as many people in cages as we do
three millions you think it's crazy on a
percentage basis yeah yeah I just
absolutely nuts and the other thing I
would say is I don't think that I would
abolish the federal reserve but I would
definitely make material changes and
really with the idea that inflation is
the largest driver of wealth inequality
in America and so figuring out a way to
address that probably not going as far
as just absolutely getting rid of the
federal reserve something in there Sallu
asks you not including your investments
which five startups IPOs are you most
excited for yet startup IPOs that you
are excited for I think draftkings is
gonna be super interesting in the sense
that that whole space around sports to
include eSports etc is gonna be really
big
great um yeah I think that'll be big
especially if they can crack into like
financial betting right you start
getting into all that kind of stuff I
think will be interesting prop bets
right like what do they call those
trading markets they call them
I mean imagine when they start betting
I'm like how long is Jim Cramer's you
know monologue gonna be at the start of
you know whatever TV show yeah like we
win the press or who's gonna be
president in the United States right who
will be vice-president absolutely
yeah those profits are really
interesting so I think that space is
interesting
definitely the cannabis space I think is
still very very under appreciated by a
lot of people I don't just have an
individual company there a company that
I think actually doesn't get enough love
in the United States
we're investors so I'm definitely biased
is Robin Hood or not Robin Hood is Robin
Hood competitor eToro
yeah in Europe and so for everything I
know
eToro is actually a bigger business but
much lower valuation and so they've just
done it in Europe Robin Hood's in
America and now they're trying to like
switch places right where you torchon
come to the u.s. from I was trying to go
international so this give me like the
burr
lift kind of competition or yeah yeah
but but it's interesting because uber
and lyft both started in San Francisco
and then we went through global
domination at the same time right two
different strategies but but so same
type of rollouts sounds like merge yeah
and create they could merge it and also
they there's a question of uber and lyft
you could put both on your phone and
just see who's the cheapest who has the
fastest car to get to you yeah I don't
think you do that with a brokerage
account no that's a little hard yeah at
North right I mean these things are it's
I think it's an Ender not an or two like
you might have Netflix and Disney if you
see value in both of the platforms they
do something slightly different unless
they're not commoditize and they have
the same offering you might have two
right I could see people as people as
the gamification of Finance continues
and people have what is it coinbase is
the big you know app for crypto trading
yeah you'd have like coinbase
wealthfront Robinhood eToro you might
have like six or seven of these apps
eventually and yeah you might have Bank
of America or Morgan Stanley some old
ones that have these janky apps but you
know I think that they're gonna have
these like super refined set and people
might just bounce between them alright
my turn okay
what's the what's your best Elon Musk
story that no one's ever heard before
okay Wow you know I try
not to talk about elan all that much
because we're obviously very good
friends and I you know it he's so famous
that it is you just people are obsessed
with him so it's really crazy but I'll
say the one that I think is kind of
interesting is I had a birthday party
for a friend of mine and Elan came jeff
bezos came and sam harris was there and
i introduced Sam and Ilan to each other
and then I think Ilan and Bezos had
maybe met once before or traded emails
but I basically introduced them to each
other again reintroduced them at my
house which was you know I think Blue
Origin was just getting started it
wasn't really that big of a deal but
that was a very interesting circle to be
in you know 12 year 10 12 years ago when
you're sitting there with Sam Harris
Bezos and Elon and it was really before
Elon has got this you know ginormous
reputation he has here now right he had
just started SpaceX and now I don't know
if he was CEO of Tesla at the time but I
thought that was a pretty you know being
in my garden at my little house in
Brentwood with those three people was
that what was their conversation they
stare at each other like commander you
know gladiators annoy people were most
interested in Sam Harris who you know
was really talking about at the time you
know consciousness the you know where is
consciousness come from was a big
discussion we used to have back then and
we used to talk about AI a lot because
Elon was very into AI and Sam was very
into consciousness and then also talking
at the time about religion and you know
Sam is obviously very well known atheist
then he became very interested in AI and
you know psychedelics meditation he's
got a really interesting range and that
those were some of the funnest
conversations I've been involved in in
my life
and I've been involved in a lot of great
conversations but Sam myself and Ilan
would go get dinner on a pretty regular
basis and just shoot the [ __ ] and man
you you want to feel like you're
outgunned at a dinner conversation
imagine like sitting there with you know
being me with bezos Ilan and Sam Harris
that's what I think it's probably my
best story did you ever hear Joe Rogan
in the vols episode on the Rogan podcast
yeah yeah I heard like the first hour of
it it's kind of hard to get to our three
of joggin huh what was so it's so funny
is I remember watching one time and
being like Joe probably has held his own
with every single guest that I've ever
heard him with except for the ball at
one point was like I felt like it was a
Ferrari in like a Toyota Camry the ball
was just like on another level and it
was so interesting to kind of watch Joe
just like yeah okay so like what else
you got for me like just keep just keep
the insights coming if I was a really
cool cat you know Duvall and I were I
think we were good friends you know in
the early days twelve years ago when we
were both like seed investors he was
doing venture hacks and I was doing
something called open angel forum and
venture hacks became AngelList and I was
the first syndicate on there and then we
we had like a little mini falling-out
because I left
AngelList and started the syndicate but
not like it not like we're not friends
falling out I think we're so friendly
but I it's kind of a bummer for me
because he became a bit of a recluse you
know he doesn't socialize anymore he and
he's pretty upfront about that he
doesn't really do a lot of podcast I
invite him on the pod you know and when
he was doing angel list he was on the
pot Hall I used to speak at every event
because I think he had something to sell
and something that he needed to promote
and I was good at that
but you know since he made all his money
and AngelList kind of hit the high notes
he doesn't want to come on the pod or
talk or he said he stopped doing pods
except his own and he just wants to be
quiet and he's kind of a recluse now
like he doesn't go out he doesn't you
know even pre-pandemic
so it was kind of bummed about that he
you know you sort of really like hanging
out with him I was like one of the more
interesting people I knew but I think
he's just gotten to floss off
- introvert I mean look part of it is we
probably get the benefit of him doing
all that but also the people that knew
him and hung out with him the most right
like you're saying hey you know maybe
can't go to dinner with summer or
whatever but uh-huh
people come with in III remain a fan and
I think you know that the thing I loved
about San Francisco before this kind of
like you know polarized country with
Trump and the left and the right being
at each other is when one of the things
that attracted me to our industry was
how independent and free thinking and
tolerant people were San Francisco used
to be the ultimate tolerant place in
terms of people thinking differently you
know and you know somebody like navall
or Tim Ferriss just it was like a really
interesting eclectic group of people who
did not agree with each other and love
to debate and then something happened
and I really pin it on the Trump
presidency where just people felt
powerless or whatever things got so
charged and everybody wanted to cancel
everybody and social media certainly has
added to this where people don't feel
they can float an idea without getting
cancelled without you know and I feel
like that whole kind of thing has moved
to podcasts right and the intellectual
dark web or whatever you know where
people feel very nervous about talking
about race or religion or atheism or
psychedelics or whatever you know put
the item on the list that's hard to talk
about and people are really scared to
have conversations do you think that
that will lead to people leaving San
Francisco started in that and that
changes the way you've got to invest
whatever changes the way I've got to
invest but you know Tim Ferriss left
Kevin Rose left Chris Sacca left a lot
of that that early interesting cohort
which you know all did very well made a
bunch of money which you know if you're
here in Silicon Valley for a decade and
you don't make money as an investor you
know like you've really either time the
cycle totally ridiculously or you're bad
at your job right like this is a
money-printing casino the
is unlike anything that's ever existed
in the history of humanity I think
legitimately because these are real
companies getting built it's not it's
it's speculation on top of a real base
of change in the world but I'm just
saddened by it I'll be honest like it
just doesn't feel it's kind of like I
guess after the 60s New York felt like
oh yeah Bob Dylan's not playing on
Bleecker Street and the folk movements
gone and you know it kind of feels like
the 70s or something where it's like oh
yeah it used to be really cool and
innovative but now it's not right like
that
it's something's been lost and that's
why I'm actually I think the pandemic
will be a silver line that comes out of
it is it's a reset and people are
leaving and not seeing the reason to
live in New York not seeing the reason
to live in San Francisco well that'll
make all this office space and all this
all these apartments super cheap
hopefully in the coming years and then
you start the cycle anew right where
another group of people is like yeah you
know there's some really smart people
there and there's capital there and
maybe we get a reboot or maybe it's
Austin you know it seems like a lot of
people are picking Texas and Florida
which are places that you know have low
tax and they're much more classic
America more right-wing probably they've
typically been red states I guess far as
a purple would you move would you leave
San Francisco yeah of course I mean I'm
not like particularly tied to here I
think it's the best thing for my
business but I'd consider it I mean I
would really love to move back to New
York and buy the Knicks that's kind of
my my long-term goal right now
you know and I loved living in LA but I
would consider living in Austin I like
Austin I was kind of looking at houses
there you know if the pandemic were like
gonna become a permanent situation my
accelerator moved to virtual so you know
it's not like I have to be physically
here anymore
and now the podcast is virtual so not by
choice I you know I want people you came
to the studio right like when we head to
her first podcast and I told you
probably like yeah when you can will I
love to have you on the pod when you're
here next or a book a trip around and
it's excused to come out and you did a
bunch of meetings when you're out here
but I insisted on people be in person I
would never do a remote
now I've only done remotes so I was the
same way
I literally would not do it pretty much
unless people were there in person and
now it's like I you know what maybe I
just go hundred percent remote do you
feel like what do you feel you've lost
and gained in the interview process and
doing the pod the remotes the consistent
quality of guest is much better remote
because obviously you don't have to
worry about people being physically in
New York City Coran hub so you can
always get people to come on it sounds
where do people have never done it
before but you'll get it like the
quality of the conversation
maybe you just lose 5% or 10% of the
quality great because there's just
something about being in person sitting
across from somebody and look at them in
the eye and have the conversation so you
know is it better to have higher quality
guests with a 5% less yes you know
valuable conversation probably yeah
that's what I've come to the conclusion
of is I'm get I have the same
experiences it's easier to get folks
because they don't have to leave
wherever they are and they all have set
up their podcasting studio now so it's
not like asking him to turn on zoom or
get a microphone or put an ethernet
cable in their computer is a it's a hard
thing because they're like yeah you know
I need to do that I need to get a green
screen into your lives for my zoom
meetings yeah this is an excuse for me
to do it
I feel like my edge was in person I got
maybe 10 to 20 percent more out of
guests but I'm not sure that my audience
notices that right so I feel like I'm so
good in person with a person that I
would only do it and now I feel like I
may have I may have gotten 10 percent
better at interviewing you know like
yeah I'm actually surprised I saw
somebody tweeting about I forget who it
was so I can't even credit but somebody
was like hey we should create a work
from home box which basically you pay
you know $500 and a microphone a light
green screen like all the stuff shows up
and it's just like hey get set up I'm
pretty surprised that no one at least
that I know of has tried that yet
because it just feels like in this
remote world
yeah there's four pieces of equipment
everyone needs and there's a business
there aren't how big it is but there's
definitely a business there that
somebody's gonna create we and this is
something you can copy for your podcast
if you don't do it already
we do a tech check you know I got
resources here obviously the podcast is
a big business for us but and we don't
do it for the business we do it for the
deal flow but and I just because I
personally love doing conversations I
love talking to people like you who are
interesting we actually now when we do
our tech check we just send the person a
microphone we send them a proper headset
and you know and it will send them an
ethernet dongle it may cost us a hundred
bucks to do that and it may cost us an
hour or two of the producers time but s
it it's such a great flex that we take
it seriously when a microphone shows up
and actually here is on the screen our
remote
AV checklist which we created which is
here's the empower seven one USB headset
get a 50-foot ethernet cable get the USB
C anchor USB C Ethernet hub get this USB
adapter and here's the agenda of what
we're going to do we're going to do an
internet speed test we do screen share
we're gonna run through your declan
internal quality and the fact that we in
our accelerator because we have you know
the authority over the people in the
accelerator we say if you want to be in
the accelerator you have to have an
Ethernet cabling you have to have a
proper headset like we won't let them
use air pods like you were using because
we know there's a chance the battery
will die right and we know that
sometimes the fatality comes off so we
make them buy the stupid headset you
know and and it's it's really been an
unlock for us because we don't have
technical issues because we just
eliminate them well we have very few
maybe one in 50 presentations how much
do you spend here's a question from
Oliver how much time you spend on
content creation versus your work at
Morgan Creek digital I spend more time
on Morgan Creek than content for sure
we're actually pretty similar in the
sense of all the content to me is deal
flow stuff right like it just you know
for all reasons that you do it as well I
would say that it is probably one third
content two thirds investing and and out
of the two thirds of my time that's on
investing like probably half of that is
spent with existing portfolio companies
half is looking at new companies what
people also don't realize the fatter
that their third yeah the third of the
time where you are doing these
interviews I don't know if you have this
experience but I consider this you and I
a strategy session right like there will
be some outcome for you and I hundreds
of thousands of people between our two
pockets will listen to this conversation
and get great value out of it and
hopefully some entertainment you and I
will get out of this and I'm gonna look
and go I'm gonna go home today and say
maybe we should put one two or three
percent into Bitcoin and make a big
trade right because I've been sitting on
that trade I've been sitting on the
Bitcoin triplet listen I'll tell you
right now if you go home and you buy one
two three percent Bitcoin and you tweet
out that you did it I promise you you
will take 50% of your haters and turn
them into the biggest here's the reason
because I just thought this thing is
I thought it would have much more
volatility than its had the fact that
it's traded in and arranged to me is a
very promising side you were talking
about the volatility for me I don't
consider a 5k where went down to thirty
five hundred and ten and up to ten
thousand in the last few years is
probably the range I think I'm right
yeah you know generally right yeah and
so it's probably been around six like
that to me a success for Bitcoin the
fact that it's only been a you know a
three X range that feels pretty good for
something that has no central authority
it feels like a tight range to me
and it feels like a confidence builder
that it hasn't gone if it went back up
to 20 into 3,500 or went to 40 and then
back down to two that would be very
concerning I would stay away but four am
I right about that do you think that the
tighter range is good well one for sure
but to also like imagine if the first
three years of ember there was a public
stock price oh I mean it would have it
be chaos Hugh conducing yeah talk about
a distraction an end by the way 50
percent of the early investors would
sell because humans suck at timing
markets and so there's almost like an
adult you had an advantage right and so
did every other investor you basically
invest capital and early-stage company
it's super volatile you don't see the
volatility and you get to the other side
of it and either you made a bunch of
money or went to zero well that's what I
tell people who are getting into this
game because they have so many new angel
investors because of my book angel that
one of them today was like I'm in 18
deals and so many of these deals are
going to zero and I was like you also
invest it in the four million and the
two hundred fifty million dollar round
of calm calm you hit an outlier in 18
investments most people takes them fifty
to a hundred to hit an outlier and he's
like why just find this all so
depressing like why can't we pick
winners and why are there are there no
singles and doubles I'm like by design I
told everybody with the syndicate calm
that I'm swinging for the fences and I
want the top two or three deals to be
the absolute 90 percent of the portfolio
we're not
playing for singles and doubles and get
singles and doubles all day long in the
public market right you time it right
you hit something that doubles your
money in two years time it wrong you
lose half your money a lot of people
don't know this but there's actually in
the kind of more traditional finance
world the absolute best returning
institutions have abnormally large
allocations to venture capital so
obviously you look at Yale that they've
kind of top five always but there's two
GMO which is Jeremy Grantham's thing and
then this thing in Pittsburgh which is
of the Detrick Foundation and so Jeremy
Grantham was recently on Petra post
Shaughnessy's invest like the puppet the
best podcast and he said that he's got I
think it was 60% of his assets or in
venture capital which I thought was just
incredibly high for somebody who's not
in technology it's not a venture I mean
that's bizarrely high I wonder a trick
foundation is over 80% so they're
swinging for the fences that you know
that might be that they understand see
this is the thing people have to
understand when you make these bets on
venture funds what I try to explain to
people is you know if you look at the
history of it you might on average have
the same returns as the public markets
or a little bit less or a little bit
more but if you had the money locked up
for that period and you had a chance of
getting into a benchmark for a Sequoia
fund we're at 5x or 10x it's almost like
you know you're playing at a poker table
where every once in a while you can make
10 times the money that's at the table
right you have this like crazy outlier
and that's what I try to train people
when I'm training them on how to be an
angel investor I said listen you got to
get to 30 investments and you should
only invest the money you can afford to
lose which I say is 5 to 10 percent of
your net worth for a high net worth
person that's where I like to tell
people you know to live because if you
lose it all you lose half of it you're
probably not gonna feel it you shouldn't
feel it right but if it does go five or
10x oh my lord you're gonna feel it
because you've got a double your net
worth right and and so and this I think
it's the same market you make for a
Bitcoin which is what if it does go 100x
well I think that's generational wealth
right
even if it was if it goes a hundred X
and it was 1% you've doubled your net
worth if you put 3% into your net worth
into it I don't know what you tell
people should be in the percentage of
net worth into Bitcoin I'm interested to
hear that and it goes 500 X oh my lord
you have what happened to me with uber
or what could potentially happen to me
hopefully not going would with Kham Kham
what your centage would you tell a high
net worth individual ie me to put into
Bitcoin because right now my Bitcoin
exposure is well under 1% I think most
people are gonna end up in the 1 to 5
percent range what would you tell me
somebody who is a crazy gambler what
should I do
tell me what you want me to tell you
what I've done yeah that's one of 50 %
your 50% in a single order took over 50
percent in a single cryptocurrency I'm
just trying to get my head around that
how do you see Romi how do you sleep I
reloading at it go up and down like this
I don't look ok well that's a good
answer it's the same thing like it again
if you had a stock price if you had a
stock price on uber right I want at one
point
uber was probably way more than 50% of
your net worth and at that point if
there was a public stock price and you
were staring at it you would have sold
her you didn't like look just let me
tell you something those were a couple
of those years were a couple of the I
wouldn't say anxiety-producing cuz I'm
not like an anxious guy but those were
some of the I wouldn't even say
nail-biting but I would say I was on
high-alert about it because people kept
trying to buy my uber shares for me at 5
billion 10 billion 20 billion 30 billion
and I did liquidate some at 50 billion
and 60 billion something in that range
and then I still have a lot left and
yeah that was a little gut check moment
for me when it went down to 15 or 16
dollars during the pandemic but I just
looked at and I said bill this pandemics
not lasting forever if it is I got
bigger problems than uber stock because
we're never gonna leave our houses again
and so do I see a world where uber
doesn't exist or isn't the number one
company in the lead no I don't so I'm
sticking around right quick the other
thing too is I'm 32 right so 49 so I
yeah yeah so and so the way I look at it
is if it all went to zero and I lost 50%
that's the equivalent of somebody at 50
losing 10% right and yeah that's
probably pretty similar all right so let
me get a couple more questions for you
here Chris asked considering he shells
from Hydra deference at the time how
deep it debt is he with Bitcoin your
daddy dad with your Bitcoin position
this is money you can't come you it
you're not a mom come on that that would
be the definition of insanity to to
lever yourself up with a cryptocurrency
the craziest stories that I've heard of
people and this is like 2012 2014 there
were definitely people who sold all
their possessions I didn't hear about
people like going in debt but I've
definitely heard stories of people who
like sold their car or sold their house
whatever took the money and put it in a
coin that alone was insanity now played
out but doesn't mean it was a good
decision right in terms of the way they
made the decision but I haven't heard
too many people going into debt to my
Bitcoin Oh in the last podcast with pop
you asked him this question what company
is most likely to be the Amazon of
crypto is a great question
will it be within decentralized finance
perhaps we still don't know the answer
does he have a better idea so I'm gonna
answer this in a little bit of a weird
way one of the companies that we
invested in very early we definitely
didn't invest enough and we've continued
to invest pretty aggressively in his
company called block 5 and the reason
why I bring them up is if you think of
the US dollar as a unit of account in
the legacy financial world the one of
the most valuable types of companies is
financial infrastructure right so banks
and so what I think coinbase and all the
other exchanges are doing is they're
acting more like brokerage type accounts
whereas block fire has specifically said
look we want to look and feel more like
wealth management they can't use the
word bank in their marketing materials
because of regulatory reasons but wealth
management services and so they can give
you a US dollar loan against your crypto
collateral they have an interest-bearing
account where you can earn you know up
to 8.6 percent Interest all Skala stuff
and to me what ends up
really interesting is in the legacy
world like if you're anywhere outside
the United States and you want to
participate in US dollars you got to go
to a bank physically walk in show them
papers like do all those crazy stuff
that the technology world forgets about
right cuz we just have stripe and
whatever crypto changes that like now
you just did an internet connection
right and so if you can just sign up for
an account and then Jason can send me
money and I didn't have to actually go
get like a traditional bank account to
me that is a Trojan horse because the
wallet is the equivalent of like
Amazon's Prime membership all right hit
me with another one hit me
pop well how was your target percentage
ownership changed in companies great
question when I was a scout for Sequoia
ten years ago I was put in twenty five
fifty K checks that generally was well
under one percent then I had my first
fund launched fund one
like whatever seven years ago started to
own one two three percent so for some
like superhuman we owned 2% then we had
the syndicate and for something like
calm we did a little bit from our fund
and a bunch from the syndicate put in
three hundred seventy eight K own 5% and
so 5% of a billion dollar company 50
million dollars well under 1% of a fifty
billion dollar company hey 100 million
dollars like you can you can see that
owning a larger percentage does better
now we have our accelerator where we get
six percent of the company in a company
like let's say fit bond which has been a
breakout company for us which is a
subscription app that's doing over 10
million a year so that would you know
generally these companies get 10 times
20 times top-line revenue if they're
high-growth could be as little as 5
could be as high as 30 in our world but
let's just put it at 10 then we will put
in money from our syndicate and our fund
and we're on our third fund now so we'll
put a little more money in and target
now is 10 to 20 percent in the winners
and so we are acting more like a seed
fund slash venture fund but we will be
totally fine with 5% and we'll be
totally fine with 20% and so you never
want to miss that in a great company and
we now will make regularly 5 or 6 bets
because
the syndicate a lot of the members keep
one Abed keep wanting they want to keep
betting even if the company's had a
hundred million or 150 or 250 million we
had a lot of the calm calm investors not
want to sell at the 250 we did sell 10
percent when I hit 250 million
we had other ones who wanted to buy and
those people who bought you know maybe
they did forex their money or 5x and
maybe ultimately they'll do 10x
hopefully maybe even 20 but they're not
going to do 200 right this is not a it's
not possible but when you get into those
later stages you're obviously reducing
risk massively and so it's a balance it
was a great question and I also like to
have a board seat to let's do I have any
more here for pomp let's see who is
actually interviewing who you guys
should make up your mind that's a good
observation TAS is a funny one which one
of you is more confident that's
interesting do you feel confident in
what you do do you feel like at the age
of 32 knowing what you know do you feel
on a scale of 1 to 10 how confident are
you in your ability I'm gonna separate
investing from the content stuff right
the content stuff much more confident in
the really because it's my personal
opinion so just affect it like I know
what how I think now you have clarity of
your own thought yeah and I know what
I'm good at what I'm not good at and
like you just more self-aware right
investing it's very much like the more
you learn yeah you're improving there
but you also realize the less you know
type situation right and so I think that
different things call for a different
level of confidence but definitely
investing is a every day you're like
damn there's people out there who are
really really good at this game and I'm
improving and they're still pulling away
right you've only been how long have you
been doing it a decade or half a deck if
I know full four and a half five years
usin yeah I think when you get a decade
under your belt and you get a couple of
big wins that's what really tips over
for you and then you start to realize
like you're saying who you are you have
that self-awareness you realize things
are out of your control and that the way
you get good at this is by consistently
showing
been doing the work so I feel supremely
confident just on the investing side of
the business
I feel supremely confident because I'm
so aware of the randomness of it that I
am at peace with never hitting an uber
again knowing that I can make an
exceptional career out of hitting robin
hood's and comms thumbtacks
you know Trello is wealth fronts
whatever Desktop metals I don't need to
have Grand Slams
or three-piece I can just win a
championship every two years right and
that's just that's a great career right
you don't need to be Michael Jordan you
could be Kobe you could be Shaq with
four you could be the Warriors with
three rings right and on a interview
basis with the content I feel like I
could sit with anybody and interview
them and my blood pressure would not
change and I would be able I could sit
across from Trump or Obama or Putin or
Kim jong-un I don't think my blood
pressure would change and I would have
absolute fearlessness and asking them
any question so I feel like I'm probably
slightly more confident you but I'm 17
years older than you so I should be yeah
that's fair but it feels like you're
very see I I don't think I had the
self-awareness that you maybe had at 32
when I was running my first media
empires my little mini media empires
with silicon on reporter and web blogs
Inc that's a super important observation
I think you're making which is you have
to be aware of your own limitations
right and that's what I've learned is
when I see Sequoia and I worked with
Sequoia I was like so in all of them and
then I realized oh you know what they do
better than everybody they show up for
[ __ ] work and I see all these people
I know and my contemporaries who don't
go to work anymore they're [ __ ]
around and not actually showing up at
the office putting the pandemic aside I
would go to Sequoia and I would just be
like there's Michael Moretz there's Jim
gets there's a Doug Leone
there's rule off there's Alfred Lin
they're all in the office all day long
and you know what they're doing
meeting with founders that's it there's
no
no big secret here to their success
other than they just work harder than
everybody else
and they do it consistently and it
compounds and it compounds and it
compounds right I mean in a way if you
look at Warren Buffett and Charlie
Munger and I know Dave portney is doing
is like you know I'm smarter than them
or whatever you know what it's
completely possible Davis will Dave do
it for five decades will he show up for
work for for ten years and do it
I think Dave's out in three weeks I
think he's had none you how long do you
think he does daily day trading well
over as a day daily day trading is
different than in I'm an advantage
because you probably don't know the
backstory for him so he started bar
stool so you'll love the story he
started bar stool I think those chosen
3004 and he started actually as a
physical newspaper but uh I didn't know
that is he oh yeah and here's the best
part is he literally went and stood at
the trains in Boston and was like
handing the amount like a paper boy
that's what I did with my magazine so he
died reporter I used to hand it out of
parties and I put in my masthead it said
Jason Calacanis CEO editor publisher and
paperboy I literally put the word
paperboy that's hilarious it so he did
this eventually started the online like
blog right and then officially social
media comes along all this kind of stuff
and it wasn't so she started 2003 chosen
four and if remember the story correctly
was until I think 2015 may be when
churnin made the first investment and
you know they valued the coming at
fifteen million bucks I bought 50% of it
and the way that this current CEO Eric
intervene tells it she's like shows up
to work for the first day as the CEO and
she's like there's like checks laying
around the office that are uncashed like
these guys have no clue what they're
doing with their graded content right so
you know look it's a somebody who sticks
it out for now almost 20 years all right
so then I'll get more credit here's the
thing about him or about that story that
I think is you know super important what
you don't know about business you can
learn but being able to create a bait
great product is the true gift and skill
in the world and if you can make
something that is a trend
send in product and whatever you think
about you know call your daddy or
barstool sports or whatever I don't even
know what their products are besides
those two whatever you think about them
they have connected with a very large
audience in a very deep meaningful way
he is a savant at making content that
they have again captured the one thing
that I think people are just now
catching up to which is I sell time he
who holds the audience has all the power
now yes because you know I mean if
Ivonne's are actually a very good
example this you cannot quote unquote
cancel Elon Musk
because Elon Musk has a bigger audience
than every single media corporation
writes got 30 million followers right
you know he can ride a rescued anybody
he could just route around the press and
if he gives it away that's what trumps
doing right that as Trump has the same
thing where I mean there's many people
both political not political across both
Joe Rogan falls into this category it's
just they have a bigger audience on a
very small percentage you know I reach
more people in my podcast and when I go
on to CNBC right I still do CNBC it's
just a different group of people and I
just love the challenge of going in
there and dunking on everybody and
having fun with it because it's
entertaining for me and fun but that's
the other thing is people forget fun
like you can see we're having fun in
this conversation Dave is having fun
Elon is having fun Chamath is having fun
and that is important you have to love
the journey and this not require
changing oh there's another okay we go
versus no revelation meat that I they
tried to console me on speaking of being
canceled they didn't cancel me on that
one no you ready yeah I saw you go on
CNBC I think the last time you were on
and you had the one of the fire iasts
hot takes and segments I've seen in a
while foot boy here we go
what is the one thing if you went on
tomorrow you would [ __ ] and complain
and yell and scream about what's like
the one thing that's top of mind right
now
that you would just go crazy on
television over that is a good one yeah
i interesting I forgot what I went I
think it was I think was a duck and
Facebook
oh yeah that's infuriating to me yeah
that was the you know just the fact that
people don't get it after her like you
know how many years he's been doing the
same thing you know right now I am
particularly upset at the lack of
leadership in this goddamn country from
top to bottom
now you'll see some great moments like
Cuomo doing his daily briefing and the
reason that Cuomo doing you know a
20-minute briefing with twenty slides
seems so extraordinary and it's not I
consider that table stakes you and I do
that every day but the fact that he does
that and the fact that Trump or London
breed here in San Francisco who gets
credit for some things but this city is
a disaster or the governor of this state
Gavin you know they just have done a
terrible job communicating and leading
and leadership is absolutely critical in
a crises and when there's a crises
that's when you find out if you actually
elected somebody who has any [ __ ]
idea of what they're doing and I'll go
off on the rail right now the fact that
Trump or pence and these [ __ ] can't
walk up to the microphone with a goddamn
mask on and say I'm wearing my mask
right now but everybody's six feet away
from me I'm gonna take it off you should
wear your mask too because there's zero
downside to it and it costs 10 cents for
these and they're available free
everywhere at every post office every
cop has a bunch in their car you can get
them for free and why wouldn't we do it
because man people losing their job
sucks and not being able to go out and
have our lives and go to school sucks so
just wear this mask please and if you
don't wear it and you see somebody not
wearing it you should just all say shame
on you and just say shame like they did
in Game of Thrones and if we all do that
we'll be fine I just did a better job
off the top of my head then 9 out of 10
politicians right
and then the fact that nobody can go on
TV and say listen not all cops are
criminals and we have a serious problem
in you know how policing is done we need
to sit at a table and we need to just
look at the hundred calls that come into
a police precinct every day and decide
who should respond to them because trust
me the police do not want to come to a
domestic dispute that could be resolved
by a social worker they do not want to
go to an addicted person or a mentally
ill person who could be handled by a
counselor we all are on the same team
let's make a new plan and start fresh
today and for the love of God please do
not resist arrest and for the love of
God please do not take your gun out of
the holster and shoot somebody who's
running away both parties need to stop
this immediately and we have to realize
we're all Americans and we have to be on
each other sides and nobody wants to go
to a funeral whether it's a cop's
funeral or it's just somebody who had a
couple of drinks and as it is eating a
goddamn chicken sandwich and the Wendy's
[ __ ] drive-through does not need to
[ __ ] die it's in [ __ ] infuriating
and that's what I would say if I was
allowed to curse on CNBC I'm sorry I'm
getting all emotional about it
but you know I come from a family of
cops my brother was a cop my cousins a
cop my uncle's a cop fought my
grandfather's a firefighter it's a hard
job and then on the other side you have
these sadistic insane people kneeling on
somebody's neck and they just torturing
them to death or shooting somebody in
the back who you just had a 40 minute
conversation with I mean let the guy run
away you have his driver's license you
know who he is and we don't have leaders
who can do this and that's the goddamn
problem is you need to have a leader who
can come out and say it the way I said
it which is be a goddamn human being and
and understand that we're all on the
same team called humanity we're all in
the same Rock planet Earth we're all in
the same country America we're supposed
to have some common decency and some
common thread amongst us to get through
these problems together and leaders are
so self-absorbed and clueless and
incompetent that they can't just say
what I just said
right oh the
definitely one aren't saying that and
two you know whether they say common
sense isn't so common anymore right now
it's this weird thing where you get the
three tweets and and the what are
perceived to be votes by having a very
black-and-white view of the world well
it's not black and white but uh no idea
that nobody should die either a cop or a
civilian is is not there should not be a
controversial wild idea like that sounds
like pretty simple objective right but
you know there's somebody who'll take
this clip and say cancel Jason cuz he
says not all cops or not you know
criminals and that something other side
will say like well you know you ran from
the cops you sold their taster you
deserve to get shot like literally those
two statements will get more likes and
retweets then what you and I would say
is just nobody wants to die no mom and
father wants to bury a son or daughter
nobody wants to go to a funeral we all
want to die of old age in a you know
playing checkers somewhere and [ __ ]
our pants and a diaper at 92 like how
great would it be if the two of us I'm
92 and you're 82 and we're sitting here
in a you know chopping it up on a
podcast playing chess you know or our
brains are on something and you're a
gazillionaire because of your Bitcoin
well and the Knicks have three rings you
know three championships you know trust
me you want to see me cry the Knicks in
a ticker tape parade I'll be bawling
I'll be bawling that that is one
interview I would pay to watch as you um
Dolan going at it you know here's the
thing about James Dolan he wants to play
music and being the son of a billionaire
and inheriting a bunch of were money and
a bunch of responsibility is a big
burden he doesn't want to do this job he
wants to play music he should sell now
the market couldn't possibly be at a
bigger peak he can get a ton of money
for it and you know what god bless go
play the blues when you see him playing
the blues he is smiling I saw him play
go find a church with Drew
and a bunch of other people now people
it's easy to make fun of somebody you
know who's not a professional musician
and who's a trust-fund kid but he's that
sure joy and then I see him sitting at
the garden and he looks utterly
depressed and sad there's a message to
James Dolan pursue your life's work
which is singing the goddamn blues and
you love it I see it on your face and
you know what
he loves to go to a club of ten people
or 20 people and just play the blues
there's a video of him online where
somebody was yelling at him sell the
Knicks while he's playing some music
festival he's playing a music festival
in the afternoon with 20 people in front
of a stage and he is loving it he's a
billionaire he owns the next the Rangers
Radio City Music Hall the beacon he's
not happy about that he's happy being
the opening act to the five other
opening acts and he's humble and in pure
ecstasy
dude that James do that Jim sell the
next to me give me the goddamn next just
give to me please just give me them next
let me do it I will get it done I
promise you I'll get it done and I will
give you all the credit in the world for
having the foresight to pick me as the
next owner of the New York
knickerbockers thank you James Dalton
what's Percy what's your dream what's
your dream pump giants the giants yeah
yeah come on you know my dad's two
season tickets and i used to go to phil
simms that phil simms and lawrence
taylor I was at all those games
I watched Lawrence Taylor he'd come out
of that halftime he'd done three or four
lines of blow and he would run through
the air he would run through the lie to
just he'd get two or three sacks at a
game he sat there watching it and Phil
Simms was just like we would just be
doing the like prevent defense we would
run the ball they would never let Phil
Simms throw it but we won we won the
underdogs what and man you watch
Lawrence Taylor oh my lord that was like
watching an alien
like it was literally like watching a
predator playing with a bunch of humans
you know the predator the movie I've
watched on my daughters they like a feat
well I'm actually had a predator in the
middle of a football game what would
happen
that was what Lawrence Taylor did has
anybody ever done anything equivalent to
what he did in terms of sacking people
and just being so incredibly
intimidating probably not the only
person I could think of a different
position but maybe like a Sean Taylor if
he had gotten to play a little more but
other than that I mean not this just not
that broke that guy's leg remember that
Isaac oh I mean when has anybody ever
gotten sacked and broken their leg is
that the only time that's ever happened
in the in the history of the NFL I got
to think it is all right listen
you've been listening to the pump and
this Wiggins startups crossover
everybody who's in my audience go
subscribe to pump
you heard him here today he's awesome he
does what he does and he's a Pompano
pompe Llano on the you can't get P OMP
on Twitter who's got that somebody
literally a know a radio DJ in Texas and
it keeps trying to sell it to me and I
keep telling them to kick rocks what
does he want a grand two grand now it
wants more than that but uh it's not
tell you this for five grand or less you
should buy it I wouldn't buy it for ten
I would buy it for five yes what he
wants the thing was ten all right listen
to the come on man
DJ guy he'll give you the I'll give you
five dimes five dimes and he'll give it
to you and bitcoin hurt now listen this
is the best part is uh people obviously
tag him all ties and so his only way to
fight back from that is he blocked me
here's what you do find out what his
name is before we publish it up to find
out his name and then go and always
protected go find out his name his full
name and buy every domain name possible
and on every other service get his full
name and say listen I got all your full
names for you right here you can have
all your full names I'll trade you those
you give me that right it's not a bad
idea but
do don't publish the show until he does
it so get his full name get his last
name go by his last name net org calm
said listen I got a collection of 300 I
got the Instagram name for you
I got everything and then you trade him
those for what you have because I've had
people do that with me before and you
know it's it's a compelling trade
sometimes you know sometimes somebody
needs like a couple of draft picks or
they need a point guard and you trade
for the point guard knowing I know what
I hurt you know what I heard you have
well I heard that you have at fortune I
have added fortune and at Libra and
Libra they tried to buy for me and we
couldn't get a consulting agreement done
you're not allowed to sell these things
but I was gonna do a consulting agree
with them and we just couldn't get it
done because they wanted to talk to me
on the phone the Facebook people and I
just like to told them I was like listen
I if you want it I'll break bread with
you we'll talk about it but I just
please stop calling me on the phone just
send money I'll do a consulting gig for
you and then you can have the domain
that's the way to do it right is you
can't sell the handle but you could sell
your consulting services so you could he
could be a consultant to you and you
could pay him a Bitcoin for something
else and throw in the domain name or
whatever but how you got at lebra don't
evil woman well no it was I in the early
days somebody on my team
got all the signs of the zodiac for me I
also have contests I have I have
contests I have also have autos I got a
bunch of handles we use them we have at
video games I have that Santa Monica I
got a bunch of weird ones on the Twitter
all right listen everybody we'll see you
next time on the pump podcast and this
week in startups pop you got to say
goodbye to your audience go subscribe to
this week in startups Jason knows what
he's doing day you lost in the synth you
go vest yeah we're not getting any
investment advice I'd rather live
describe my discovery disclaimer but we
love to gamble the end
great job pop All Right see y'all next
time that kicked ass